- [Mark] Welcome back
to the show everyone.
Whether you're a kid who's
12 years old or younger
or an adult older than 19,
you're gonna love this episode.
If you're a teenager, it
may already be too late.
- You could give God what it takes.
- Mount Rushmore may have four presidents
but it's only got room
for three baddy slashers,
Freddy Krueger, Jason
Vorhees and Michael Myers.
Or as I'd call them if I
wrote for the local newspaper,
the Enigma of Elm Street
versus the Killer of Camp Crystal Lake
versus the Haddonfield Halloween Hunk.
Ah, I miss that, improv's tough, everyone.
It's the debate you and
your friends have had since
the dawn of time, or at least 1984.
Who's the best horror movie bad guy?
Today, we're gonna settle just that
by tossing into the Vitamix
your favorite dream master,
the iconic undead goalie
and the world's meanest trick or treater.
It's about to be the
most violent, goriest,
bloodiest threesome you've ever seen.
- Welcome to my nightmare.
- Here's how we'll determine a winner.
Round one, box office.
Round two, tomato meter/audience score.
Round three, cultural relevance.
And then if I'm still alive,
we'll do a wild card
round to settle the score.
Two of these fellows
fought in a movie once
and it was a good battle,
only problem was it
appeared to end in a draw
but now we're adding Michael
Myers to the VIP list
and only one of these three
stocking stalwarts of cinema
will get bragging rights in hell,
where I believe Jason has a summer home.
Let's get it on.
(upbeat rock music)
Round one, box office.
The year was 1978, Jimmy
Carter was president,
the Pittsburgh Steelers
were etching their name
into the record books
and parents were
concerned about their kids
listening to that darn Van Halen.
But by the time October rolled around,
1978 became about one thing
this new "Halloween" movie
you had to see and keep your eyes open
the whole time to believe.
Grossing $188 million
on a shoe string budget
that adjusted barely over
$1 million in today's world,
"Halloween" was celebrated
as a horror film rebirth
and it would spawn 10 sequels/reboots
that all told, have
gross 851 million bucks
for a $77 million per film average,
those numbers are greatly enhanced
by the most recent entry
into the legendary franchise.
2018's cleverly titled "Halloween,"
which would total $165 million
in total domestic receipts.
And perhaps it was the looming
presence of Michael Myers
that inspired Jason and Freddy
to make their own movies.
J-Dogs can would be up
next beginning with 1980s
"Friday the 13th."
- Killer mommy.
- Yes, I know it was Jason's mommy
who was doing the stabbing
during the first one
but she was doing it for her boy.
So even though we don't
see the iconic Jason
trying out for the local
rec league hockey team look
until the third film,
I'm giving him credit
for the entire franchise,
it's what his mom would have wanted
and to be frank, I don't
feel like dying over it.
- That's a good boy.
- "Friday the 13th" flicks
have racked up 862 million
total bucks over the course of 12 movies
making for a golf clappable
$72 million per film average.
Strictly in terms of box office,
the gold standard is still the original,
sporting a cannon record,
$138 million resume line.
(spooky music)
And then there were two
and for most teens that would be plenty
but then 1984 happened
and not even your worst
Orwellian nightmare could compete
with the shut eye action
going down on Elm Street.
Freddy Krueger, a former
janitorial enthusiast
with a limited wardrobe budget,
debuted on the big
screen with a $68 million
total domestic hall.
Unlike his colleagues,
Fred wouldn't see his
highest solo box office
until his fourth movie,
subtitled "The Dream Master,"
grossing 113 million bucks.
Kruger and his zany one-liners
have starred in a total
of nine movies raking in a
combined bushel of $739 million,
for an average of 82 million per flick.
- No pain, no gain.
(woman screams)
- [Mark] All three fellows came
out of the box office gates
swinging for a very competitive round one.
If you look at the top
12 of their combined
best moneymaking movies,
each psychopath has
four movies on the list,
but it's "Halloween"
claiming the top two spots
with the 1978 and 2018 films respectively.
And while "Friday the 13th"
has the highest total gross
and "Nightmare on Elm Street"
boasts the highest per film average,
"Halloween" is a close
second in both categories.
And we have to point out that Mikey
doesn't have the advantage of
a successful crossover movie.
"Freddy versus Jason" did happen
and made $128 million on
its way to disappointing me
by not declaring a true winner.
- Who gives a fuck what you think?
(woman screams)
- [Mark] Sealing the deal for me
is the return on investment.
All three franchises burst onto the scene
with a remarkable ability
to spin straw into gold.
Freddy's rookie flick cost
just $1.8 million at the time,
while Jason's mom's opening
budget was even lower
at $550,000 but it was Michael,
alligator arms when the
check arrives, Meyers
who got his movie made for
just $325,000 at the time.
And it was probably that initial success
that made film executives say
"Hey, can we do that in a camp
or over on that Boulevard
named after a tree?"
- Every town has an Elm Street.
- Even though he kills
people without remorse,
Michael makes tons of money for his crew,
so he gets to win in round number one.
- You can't kill the Bogeyman.
- Round two, tomato meter/audience score.
Before I asked the usual question
of sure you made money but
were the movies any good?
Let's go ahead and free the cats
from their environmental
friendly, reusable bag.
Each of these gentlemen have
made some real stinkers,
you think a dismembered body smells bad?
Wait until you get a whiff of how rotten
some of these movies
are on the tomato meter.
- [Freddy] You really
shouldn't fall asleep in class.
- All three guys have multiple movies
that are 15% or below,
it's Jason taking the brunt
of it with a record low 8%
for that time he took Manhattan.
Taking an unwanted silver
metal is millennial of note,
Paul Rudd in "Halloween:
The Curse of Michael Myers"
earning just 9%.
- Sorry.
- And maybe the most disappointing of all
would be the 2010 remake of
"Nightmare on Elm Street,"
which scored 15%.
That's supposed to course correct
to get the franchise
back on the right path.
Huh, uh, no, oh, no Robert England.
Look, I love you, Jackie you
were great in "Bad News Bears"
but there's only one Freddy
and his name is Robbie.
- It's a boy!
- [Mark] But so what if
they've had some missteps
in their time?
There's some good in there too, right?
Yes, in fact, there's a ton of it.
The tomato meter top 10
features two movies from Jason
including his only fresh flick,
his mom's "Friday the 13th" at 64%
and three "Halloween" movies
headlined by the overall clubhouse leader
and grand daddy of them all
1978's original with 96%.
- Was it the Bogeyman?
- As a matter of fact, it was.
- But it's Freddy who has
five movies in the top 10,
hey, that's one for each razor blade.
Topping out with his original
1984 introduction at 94%.
And it's worth noting that while the 2010
"Nightmare on Elm Street"
tanked with critics,
the 1994 Metta tour de force
West Craven's new nightmare
is currently at 80%.
- Miss me?
- [Mark] But before I
give the round to Fred,
let's take a gander at
that audience score.
"Nightmare" and "Halloween"
each sport three movies
that made it fresh with audiences,
meanwhile, "Friday the
13th" only has its original
bragging about being fresh barely at 60%.
(woman screams)
And for overall audience score average,
it's once again between the
dream dude and the holiday guy.
Freddy's average is
50.1%, Michael's is 50.3%.
You see kids, voting does matter.
- Tell 'em Freddy sent ya!
- And so does the tomato meter.
Freddy dominates average score over there
winning easily with 50.4%
over its closest competition,
Michael Myers, at 37%.
So, Sir Lord Krueger, round two is yours
and I'm sure you'd like to celebrate
with one of your classic
comedic barb's, have at it.
- Now I'm playin' with power!
- Round three; cultural relevance.
Hey, when it gets to the real reason
why we're doing this vid,
because people still care,
they love these three awful human beings
and even decades after their debuts,
no one in the horror game has come close
to the cultural relevance
of the big three.
Ghostface, good effort,
Darth Maul looking guy
from 'Insidious," cool,
weird dude from "Sinister,"
update your home movie technology.
Since Mikey came along first
and decided to base his murderous rampages
around a popular holiday,
it's safe to say he's made it
into the hall of killer fame.
It already impressive that "Halloween H20"
saw a dramatic uptick in box office
from previous entries in the franchise
and then to do it even more
successfully 20 years later?
We still crave Michael Myers.
If you need more evidence,
think of the iconic
slasher films before 1978,
"Peeping Tom," "Black Christmas,"
not exactly household names.
The only reason we'd mentioned "Psycho"
is because of that legendary shower scene
and remember who was
bleeding chocolate syrup?
Janet Lee, AKA Jamie Lee Curtis' mom.
Life is just one big NASCAR track, kids.
- We've all had bad things happen to us,
the trick is to concentrate on today.
- [Mark] We might not have
Mr. Myers' competition today
if not for his inaugural movie.
And that's flick also
popularized the use of panaglide,
which is how John Carpenter managed
to get those super eerie
first person glimpses
from Michael's perspective.
Audiences were frightened,
film students were like,
"Oh, it looks so smooth!"
But maybe carpenter's best
contribution to the legacy
of the shape is the musical
score that he composed himself.
You know it instantly and it may be second
only to "Jaws" as far as
themes that can instantly scare
the hell out of you.
Oh, do I smell a crossover?
Could a shark pull off
wearing that "Halloween" mask?
Speaking of memorable themes,
how about a little kid belting out
♪ One, two, Freddy's comin' for you ♪
♪ Three, four, better lock your door ♪
Ominous lyrics plus singing children?
That's a Coca Cola level formula
that equals pure creepiness.
- [Freddy] The only thing
to fear is fear himself.
- Freddy Kruger also has
his staple autumnal wear,
the sweater, the filthy
hat, the Dockers, the glove.
Sure, it may not be quite
as strong as adamantium
but Wolverine can only use
his claws when he's awake
or having a really intense dream.
Like, what happens constantly
to those teens on Elm Street?
What separates Fred from the
pack is his speaking ability,
yeah, he can talk, as a matter
of fact, he won't shut up.
- Wanna suck face?
I don't believe in fairytales!
Bon appetite, bitch.
- His one liners are part
and parcel for any good entry
into the "Nightmare on Elm Street" canon.
Sure, they occasionally get ridiculous
but it's hard to accuse him of dad jokes
when you're running for your life.
Plus, it gives him a
backup career as a comic,
for tickets, head to unclefreddyslays.net.
- Got your nose!
(woman screams)
References by everyone
from the Fresh Prince
and DJ Jazzy Jeff to Nicki Minaj
have kept Freddy Kruger alive and well
in the cultural zeitgeist,
plus, he had Dokken do his soundtrack
for the "Dream Warriors,"
which proves that the music
in hell kicks way more ass.
So now it looks like only Jason Vorhees
is standing in the way
of another Freddy round
- I'll let Jason have some fun.
- You hear that?
The dude doesn't even
need a proper theme song,
he can just chill us by
queuing up that weird breathing
track on Pro Tools.
And while Jason certainly
won't be competing
against Michael Phelps for
swimming records anytime soon,
his contribution to
athletics is undeniable,
that hockey mask, it already look to neat
but now that a serial
killer from beyond the grave
has donned one, it's the go to mask
for anyone needing a last
second costume party idea.
Jason has made the rounds including
winning an MTV Lifetime Achievement Award
appearing on the "Arsenio Hall Show"
and blessing us with
some of our first degrees
of Kevin Bacon.
But it's not just the fame of Jason
or his banned Nike commercial
that makes him an icon,
it's the day he represents.
So, the curse of Friday the 13th
actually finds its
origins well before 1980,
it dates back to early
Christian mythology.
Friday was the day of the last supper
and who is the last apostle
to show up at Applebee's?
Yep, it was Judas, that Judas.
He was the 13th guest on that Friday
but all the Jesus plus ones in the world
can't compete with what
that day represents now,
when a Friday the 13th hits,
weird things happen to people.
Some folks stay indoors,
call in sick to work,
shut the blinds, others
celebrate it with a party
that even the earliest of
All Hallows' Eve participants
would appreciate and why is all that?
Because of Jason Vorhees.
Had it not been for his
consistent pole position
lodged in the forefront of our brains,
every time we go camping,
watch an NHL game and especially
wake up on certain Fridays,
no one would bat an eye
at the 13th of the month
but thanks to Jason, with a
hockey assist from his mom,
Pam, Friday the 13th
and is favorite mascot
serve as a looming
reminder to tread lightly.
Jason gets the wind and round
three and once you know it,
we're all tied up going into,
let's see if you're a hockey fan,
we've already had three
periods, so overtime?
And yes Freddy, this one's for you.
It's sudden death!
- Sticks and stone may break my bones
but nothin' will ever kill me.
- And now it's time for the
wild card round, iconic moments.
Okay, because this is a safe space
where we can be honest with one another,
this round is all about kills,
I didn't wanna shout that from the rooftop
at the beginning of the episode
but now that you've
stuck with me this long,
who's the best at fictional murdering?
Step right up Voorhees family,
Like any great mother, Mrs. Jason
did her son a huge solid
by showing him the ropes.
Unfortunately, these ropes
were actually machetes
and chain saws, you know what,
maybe she wasn't that
good of a mom but oh boy,
was her son ever good at killing!
Jason punched the dude's head clean off
when he took Manhattan, he
just popped that sucker out
like it was tee ball.
And in "Friday the 13th" part four,
check out the sick corkscrew
maneuver that Jason performs
on none other than Mr.
George McFly, Crispin Glover.
"Hey you, get your damn hands off him."
But my favorite Jason moment
is when he straight up
folds a poor sucker in half,
like he's breaking down
boxes to be a good recycler.
This kill happens in the film
where Freddy and Jason square off,
they weren't just batting over turf,
it was a war to see who is
the best baddy of all time.
So now, the undead demon from
Elm Street has the floor.
- [Freddy] It's time to
put this bad dog to sleep.
- I love Freddy because so
many of his kills are on brand,
the guy haunts you in your dreams,
so naturally he loves a
good bedroom bloodbath.
Johnny Depp gets sucked into his own bed
but Fred also got in on the
late eighties waterbed craze
as evidenced in the "Dream Master."
- How's this for a wet dream?
- For the best Kruger kills,
go down to "Nightmare on Elm
Street 3: Dream Warriors."
A group of troubled teens,
many struggling with addiction,
now have to wrestle with
burns bastard son too?
And it didn't go well,
poor Tina finally gets to be on television
but not in the way she hoped
and this fella became
a literal meat puppet
years before that band hit it
big with "Backwater Swirl."
But more so than any one kill,
it's the spirit of the sick
demented fun that Freddy brings
to each tragedy that keeps
us coming back for more.
- Let's get high.
As opposed to say, Michael Myers,
who rather than sick pleasure,
seems to be motivated
by a constantly running
set of batteries hell
bent on Halloween mayhem.
From poor Bob in the first "Halloween,"
Can we check how many fella's named Bob
actually survive horror movies?
I'm betting not a lot,
maybe go by Robert from now on.
And then as if being named
Karen wasn't already tough,
look at what happens to
this one in "Halloween II"
Rob Zombie's "Halloween"
film saw the gruesome end
of our beloved Octavia Spencer's character
as well as the seemingly
indestructible Machete himself,
Danny Trejo.
Doesn't matter who you are,
Michael Myers is there to kill
you a quick and permanent.
And while both he and Jason
may not be the most
personable of movie villains,
they got their job done
with ruthless efficiency
and permanently altered our perception
of Halloween and Friday the 13th.
- Help me!
Help me!
Somebody, please, help me!
- [Mark] But it's Freddy Kruger
who not only used his
glove, his imagination
and his ability to infiltrate
dreams to win our hearts,
It was his mouth.
- Ever play in the cat?
- [Mark] Perhaps he spent
a little too much time
on the wise cracks in a few of the films
but he's the consummate entertainer,
he knows he's there to kill
teens as a means of revenge
for their parents burning
him alive years ago.
But Freddy is also well aware
there's an audience of millions
witnessing the carnage.
As much as he doesn't care
about the lives of victims,
he does care about giving us
the most bang for our buck,
the jokes, the creativity, the passion.
Whether he's in some random bedroom
or on his home court,
basement boiler room,
Freddy Kruger is the horror movie villain
that gives us his all every
time he foot in our dreams.
For that, he wins this
round and thus the match.
- I beat my high score.
- Freddy, Michael, Jason,
you're all winners in my book.
And I'm not just saying that
because I prefer to not
be hacked to pieces,
you are the champions but
it's been no bed of roses
for the legions of kills you've committed
for both personal reasons
and our entertainment value.
For funsies, you want to
know which of the big three
has killed the most?
It's Jason, making his mama proud,
the big goalie is hovering
it around 157 kills,
edging out Michael Myers' total of 140.
Freddy is bringing up the
rear at barely 40 kills
but today's match was about
quality over quantity.
Jason might win if all
three were tossed into a pit
and had to duke it out, all
other things being equal,
I'd give the tie breaker to a mom,
but not the mom you think.
Let's shout out Amanda
Kruger, Freddy's mom,
she pops up in "Dream Warriors"
as this ominous looking nun
and I think she's trying
to help Nancy and the gang
but her mere presence
scares the hell out of me.
Maybe it's the fact that she
gave birth to a child murderer
or that she's a ghost
or that she's wearing
the all white nun look,
the away uniform for any sister of mercy.
Man did he give us the best
horror movie villain there is,
the hat, the sweater,
the guy who's probably playing
the Jacksonville Comedy Zone
this weekend.
Now coming to the stage,
grab your crucifix,
it's Freddy Krueger.
But that's just one guy's opinion
and I don't live on Elm Street,
I've never been camping and
haven't trick or treated
in at least 11 months.
So now it's your turn,
vote in the comments
section for who you think
is the best of the bad.
Freddy, Jason or the O.G, Michael.
Thanks for watching everyone.
And remember, don't go
into any wooded areas,
avoid anyone named Strode on Halloween
and nap with a buddy?
Yeah, good luck with the sleep thing.
(gentle upbeat music)